hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter 14 of
after virtue after having introduced the
notion of practice and defined it to
some extent and its relations with other
key ideas such as standards of
excellence obedience to rules
achievements of goods and indeed to
virtues and after having provided a
preliminary definition of a virtue as an
acquired human quality the possession
and exercise of which tends to enable us
to achieve those goods which are
internal to practices and the lack of
which effectively prevents us from
achieving any such goods after doing all
of that Alastair MacIntyre is going to
single out and identify and to some
degree discuss three virtues in
particular that he views as absolutely
necessary and essential if we're going
to have viable practices so we we can't
just pick and choose whatever virtues we
want to work on like say I'm going to
focus just on generosity because we need
these other three you might say in order
to be able to have the practices and
there
even to be able to have the other
virtues so what are these three we might
say architectonic virtues well they are
as MacIntyre tells us justice courage
and honesty and he's not saying that
these are definitely the only ones that
we'll ever need as a matter of fact he
leaves it open as and he will discuss in
later works additional virtues but in
this section he's concentrating just on
knees and so he tells us that it belongs
to the concept of a practice as I've
outlined it and we are all familiar with
it already in our actual lives whether
we're painters or physicists or
quarterbacks or just indeed lovers of
good painting or first-rate experiments
or a well-thrown past that it's goods
can only be achieved by subordinating
ourselves that and we'll come back to
that in a moment within the practice in
our relationship to other practitioners
we have to learn to recognize what is
due to whom we have to be prepared to
take whatever self endangering risks are
demanded along the way and we have to
listen carefully to what we are told
about our own inadequacies and reply
with the same carefulness for the facts
so already he's talking there about
justice courage and honesty right so why
do we need those so so badly in order
that we can actually develop within the
practices because in order to do that
you do in fact have to choose to
subordinate yourself this doesn't mean
in some sort of dominant submissive way
or anything like that it means
recognizing that other people are
further along the path than you are that
you can learn from them and that you
can't just make it up as you go along
that oftentimes there's an entire body
of expertise that it would behoove you
to benefit from by learning from and
measuring yourself against it
so we subordinate ourselves practices
are concerned with internal goods that
is goods that can only be realized
through the context of engaging in that
practice and they provide standards of
excellence Oh
usually an entire range these are
standards for beginners this is okay for
you here's the standards for
intermediate you don't want to be like a
beginner anymore right
here's the standards for mastery level
of excellence all of those are integral
to practices and virtues as McIntyre is
understanding them so why then these
these three he tells us we have to
accept as necessary components of any
practice with internal goods and
standards of excellence these virtues
not to accept these to be willing to
cheat for example bars us from achieving
the standards of excellence or the goods
internal to the practice that would be a
violation for example of honesty when
people fake things when they print
themselves certificates of achievement
for having done something that is really
quite meaningless they haven't actually
learned the skill and we'll use an
example in music we always used to say
play it first then play it fast right
and you would see people this is also
holds in martial arts too my sensei
would always say do it first and then do
it fast meaning do the motions correctly
master the thing and then speed it up
instead of speeding it up to cover up
your mistakes another prime example of
this would be how people love to use
effects when they're you know playing
music great you know prime example would
be auto-tune four voices but a
distortion pedal is a guitarist friend
right because it covers up sloppiness if
you play clean then you can actually
hear whether you're getting the notes
right or not and whether you have some
things that you need to work on being
willing to accept that and say oh yes I
do need to work on that and not cheating
on it not trying to pass off some
inadequate performance or poorly
developed performance or one you just
happen to get lucky about as being the
genuine article is part of what it means
to be able to develop within a
so he gives it several examples here
that that illustrate why truthfulness
why justice why courage and what these
are so he says consider this example a b
c and d are friends and the st. and the
sense of friendship which aristotle
takes to be primary they share in the
pursuit of certain goods in my terms
they share in a practice d dies in
obscure circumstances a discover this
how d died and tells the truth about it
to be while lying to c so that we've got
a problem with honesty there right c
discovers the lie and here's what
McIntyre says what a cannot and that
intelligibly claim is that he stands in
the same relationship of friendship to
both B and C by telling the truth to one
lying to the other he has partially
defined a difference in the relationship
so he can't say we're all exactly the
same when it comes to this friendship
he can't be dishonest about that
McIntyre says he can have some perfectly
good explanations for that he might say
he was trying to spare C pain or he's
simply cheating C but some difference in
the relationship now exists as a result
of the lie for their allegiance to each
other in the pursuit of common goods has
been put in question
honesty covers a lot of different ground
its honesty not just towards one's self
being honest about one's own you know
current status and need for improvement
it's also honesty with other people and
in this case we have a sort of meta
honesty he could lie about the lie as
well and and that would create even more
problems and what this is going to do is
put a damper on things
McIntyre talks about justice as well he
gives another example and he says that
whether we acknowledge it or not we have
to see that we define our relations to
each other by standards of justice if a
a professor gives B and C the grades
their papers deserve but grades D
because he's attracted by blue D's blue
eyes or is repelled by D's day
he has defined his relationship to deed
differently from his relationship to the
other members of the class whether he
wishes it or not he's been unjust in
that respect right why because he says
justice requires we treat others in
respect of merits or D dessert according
to uniform and impersonal standards to
depart from the standards of justice
defines our relationship with the
relevant person in some way as special
or distinctive even if we're like
favoring them we could still be unjust
to them as well as unjust to the others
as well so justices is required within
the framework of practices and the
relationships in which we develop them
he says a little bit it's a little bit
different with courage though we hold
courage to be a virtue why because the
care and concern for individuals
communities and causes which is so
crucial to so much in practices requires
the existence of courage as a virtue
here's a great you know comparison here
if someone says he cares for some
individual community or cause but is
unwilling to risk harm or danger on
his/her or its own behalf this person
puts into question the genuineness of
their care and concern courage the
capacity to risk harm or danger to
oneself has its role in human life
because of this connection with care and
concern and now MacIntyre says it's true
there are people who are cowards and
genuinely care but there we've got some
sort of problem we've got a kind of
bifurcation going on within the human
being he says that here we go that's not
to say a man cannot genuinely care and
also be a coward but it is to say that a
person who genuinely cares and has does
not have the capacity for risking harm
or danger has to define themselves both
of them self and others as a coward so
you know if you do care about say your
child and you don't stand up for them
when they're being bullied you're a
coward and this is where I say you know
truthful this might enter and a lot of
people want to lie to themselves oh it
was
the right time for me to say something
no you probably should have said
something that was what courage word
acquired and McIntyre talks here about
you know braving danger danger could be
of all sorts it could be to one's social
status it could be to monetary loss it
could be life and limb it could be
risking another relationship it could be
you know courage is also required in
truth-telling isn't it when you have to
break something to somebody that they
don't want to hear and truthfulness is
required encourage all three of these
virtues meet up together and support
each other now another point that
McIntyre makes that's absolutely
important is that we live in societies
not every society defines these or codes
these in precisely the same way he does
say that without these we cannot
actually have the practices but he says
lutheran Pyatt estomago Conte is an
example of this brought up their
children to believe that one ought to
tell the truth to everybody at all times
whatever the circumstances or
Consequences but to take another side
traditional bond to parents brought up
their children not to tell the truth -
unknown strangers why because they
thought this could render the family
vulnerable to witchcraft in our culture
as a third example many of us have been
brought up not to tell the truth to
elderly great aunts who had invited us
to admire their new hats we're supposed
to say it's they're wonderful when
actually we think that they're you know
quite quite awful and you know in each
case it's not as if there's only one
pure standard of truthfulness
truthfulness is being interpreted within
a social matrix but you have to have
some sort of standard of truthfulness or
you're not going to get off the ground
when it comes to these practices same
thing with justice justice can be
defined differently courage can be
defined differently you know the the
notion in our society that if somebody
challenges you you have to have a duel
with them is fortunately except in some
very small subcultures you know
something that's that's gone
by the wayside but we have other ways of
being courageous so McIntyre's point is
that in order for practices to flourish
no matter where they are
we need these three virtues in
particular and so that means that these
virtues are going to be necessary for
the cultivation of other virtues which
means that they are absolutely central
to McIntyre's virtue ethics
you